remember this gal over here Caitlyn oh
God Caitlyn yeah this was uh women can't
have sorry women can have standards but
men can't um she was interesting one she
was really really interesting to me
because
um like every everything that that would
go her way she was good with and
anything that would that would go the
way of a guy you know to his benefit she
was not good with at all
uh and made a huge stink about so many
things it was um the tattoo thing was
her big one before we get into that if
anybody goes back and rewatches this
episode I think the most interesting
thing to me about Caitlyn was you can
see her body language and her level of
comfort change over the course she had
like a tank tap on and she was just like
chilling and by the end of it after we'
had some tough conversation she was C up
into
aall sweater on and just in the fetal
position essentially you know really
really interesting class on on
nonverbals and body language but yeah
her her big issue was the idea that she
had a guy that expected her to pay for
his kids schooling or chip in for his
kids schooling and yet and and and she
that was a standard that she wasn't
willing to do but on the flip side there
was an example of friend of hers who had
a tattoo of her deceased husband her um
past husband and we said well that's a
choice she made but that doesn't mean
that we have to date her or accept it
and that was where um she had an issue
she got real bent out of shape when it
was like well I'm going to disqualify
your friend because she has a tribute
tattoo of another man on her body right
like she's holding a place in her heart
she's been Alpha widowed by this guy a
constant reminder of what you will never
live up to yeah and it's like you know
this tattoo is now on on this woman's
body and we as men are not allowed to
have a standard but she's allowed to
have a standard about the way that you
know she wants to interact in
relationships and men have to look past
certain things yeah there was a lot of a
lot of moving Parts with that episode um
you know with Caitlyn and it's like they
don't have any
self-awareness around and I don't think
they'll ever go back and watch it and be
like Oh huh okay that makes sense now I
understand why you know rich and moff
were talking about things like that and
trying to enlighten me like I don't
think they'll ever come back to the
self-awareness like they'll always
be stuck on you know how it made them
feel right because women are you know
these emotional creatures and it's like
you know well how do we how do I feel
after having this this conversation you
know about this that or the other thing
and it's like I don't feel very
comfortable I'm throwing on layers on
clothes there's a pillow on my lap I'm
getting very you know pulled back and
you know angry at just about anything
that's said and it's real funny because
Jessica was sitting there on the other
side of the screen sort of just nodding
and agreeing with everything that we
were talking about it was just it was
just such a rush man again one of them
in a successful relationshipmarriage and
one of them not not yeah exactly and I
mean it's very rare that we found I
think the only one that I can think of
who was a traditional and I wish we had
been able to die I kind of dove into
this with her a little bit but I don't
remember getting a really straight
answer was was Danica was the nurse from
Winnipeg and she also so for a quick
backstory for for those that don't know
and didn't watch I originally invited
her on the show she turned me down at
first because she was seeing somebody
and she actually did what I only knew
know of two people that did this I mean
other women might have done this but I
don't know of them checked with her guy
that she was seeing or checked with hus
one of the women said let me check with
my husband let me check with my
boyfriend but only two of them have done
that and he said oh I'm not cool with it
I don't you know think it's proper to be
on a show talking about dating
relationships what if sex comes up and I
just don't think that's appropriate and
she didm me back and she said hey he's
not cool with it I'm old school I
respect him I was like Hey fair enough
like cool that's that's that's fair and
then like a week later she's like yeah
it didn't work out with the guy I'll
come on but she she
uh early 30s 33 34 and
she claimed to be very traditional and I
kind of just said well you know you she
was married before and I said well if
you're so traditional and you sort of
embody a lot of these traits and you get
on with a lot of the stuff you talk
about what's not working what are you
doing and her answer was basically I'm a
hermit I don't go out so
Jessica was a great example of somebody
who was very intentional about what she
wanted and she went out and she made an
effort and she got it and she ultimately
won the guy that she wanted to be with
whereas danak along with a lot of these
other women are just waiting for the
world to drop Prince Charming at their
front door and think that they can just
go home from their job and eat ice cream
and watch Netflix and he's just going to
he's just going to find his way to their
house because he took the wrong turn or
something like that they live in a
Hallmark movie and it's just not the
reality by any
stretch yeah um I got
another screen here queued
up uh you're going to remember these
ones cuz uh you got this smug one over
here even the even the uh pause screen
capture has you know the smug look on it
um but the title of that one was uh boss
baby calls rich and basically
you know we invited the girls on to sort
of have a dialogue and conversation and
what these two had done was essentially
plan to come on and just be like
disagreeable with no context around the
reasoning Rhyme or why and it's like you
know they don't like we don't know
anything about these gals I mean I
really know even less than you you know
before we even start the show because I
mean I'll I'll sometimes get their you
know social media you know in advance or
it's on the screen and I'll pull it up
were sort of uh chatting about something
and it's like somebody um for this
Jillian girl um looked her up in the
comments and I think she got fired from
a radio station or something like that
and there was a big story about it but
but I mean the two of them had like a
very peppered uh past even though they
were in their 30s hadn't got anything
that they wanted we were offering useful
solutions to the problems that they were
encountering and the entire context of
it was basically totally unaware of what
men want nor caring what men want and
just wanted dudes to enter their frame
um I think that can be summed up with
women wanting men to be their cheer
cheerleader I think that women have been
told somewhere somehow I don't know if
it's a function of media or Lady Gaga or
cardi b or whatever it happens to be
that women should no longer cheerlead
men and do anything useful in their life
or be respectful and instead they want
men to cheerlead them I mean we saw that
a few times there was uh another gal
that U you know was talking about dating
a a tech startup guy that was super you
know successful and she wanted him to
cheerlead her I think it was on writing
a book or
something yeah but yeah yeah yeah that
popped up a lot too yeah I mean Julian's
biggest problem with us so so Jillian
and Jordan knew each other they were
friends and that this was the first time
that I experimented with having two
people that knew each other yeah and I
thought that might open up more dialogue
and more conversation which it did but
they clearly came armed with an agenda I
mean and and
Jordan you know nailed a lot of the red
flags right off the bat single mother
two different fathers bunch of tattoos
heavily tattooed yeah um and Jillian
Jillian was far more concerned with the
way things were said than was actually
said J was was was very like I'm I'm
conservative I'm Christian I want a
traditional you know you know type of
relationship and it's like oh good so
you must be a virgin then because you've
been saving yourself for your husband
and it's like no no so like that's one
of the things that I notice a lot too is
a lot of this like I'm I'm very
conservative and very Christian and I
you know want to find a guy that you
know puts God first and all that sort of
stuff it's like good so then you must to
save yourself for your husband husband
it's like no no no I've been I've been
sharing myself with a lot of men
actually right um yeah she also fell
into the category of a lot of of women
we've seen that say you know because she
she did self admit she goes well I made
some mistakes in my 20s and I didn't
realize till I was about 27 or 28 that I
needed to change but here she is 35 and
singing like what the hell you been
doing for the last eight years right I
mean what where's the maybe you quote
unquote recognize it but even most
recently we had chrison she's you know
35 36 and she's oh I made a lot of
mistakes in my 20s but here I am dating
you know a 23y old dude that calls me
stepmom in his phone right or that um
you know
so where's the disconnect you know you
realize that it's a problem you
understand that you've got an issue and
you're not where you are what why are
you not taking this proper is it
ignorance or is it just you know is it
like an alcoholic I know I'm a I know I
have a problem but I can stop I don't
have a problem I can stop anytime I want
to right I know it's not good for me but
I can stop anytime and then now it's
know 40 years later and that anytime
turned into never I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out